hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we are in
game number nine of the 2021 world chess
championship between madness carlson and
yonepo it started to get exciting two of
the last three games have ended in a win
magnus carlson winning game number six
in game number eight when he has the
white pieces they had a break yesterday
giving nepo a day off to figure out how
he's gonna come back and play the white
pieces and get a victory today to make
things interesting he has played the
same ray lopez anti-marshall
the last four times he has tried the
white pieces so definitely interested to
see how he comes out today
you would expect him to play something
different and that's exactly what he
does starts out with c4 the english
opening
met by e6 now many times this is just
going to
get into the queen's gambit lines but
instead we see something even different
so pawn to
g3 preparing fianchetto to the king side
of the board pawn d5 and after bishop g2
then d4 from magnus cross and this is a
pretty annoying pawn to deal with knight
can't come to c3 which is typically what
you see in the english opening
and so at some point you may expect
something like pawn e3 try to break up
this pawn it can just get pretty
annoying for white knight to f3 normal
development move preparing to castle on
the king side attacking this pawn knight
to c6 development defending this pawn on
d4 castle and then bishop c5 so madness
carlson doing a good job
finding a good sharp line to defend in
this position remaining remember magnus
carlsen is up two points in this series
he doesn't have to do anything crazy but
he also wants to make sure that yanepo
cannot get the initiative at any game he
does not want to face a
loss at all it's just magnus crossland
that's the way he plays pawn to d3
solidifying this pawn chain also opening
up for this dark square bishop to get
involved into the game also opens up if
white wants to play knight to d2
position his knight over here to b3 he
has some options since he can't play
knight to c3 which is the preferred move
for
that knight on b1 knight to f6 preparing
to castle on the king side from madness
carlson knight to d2 and then a5 so
pushing a little bit on the queen side
as he prepares on the queen
to castle on the king side decides hey
yeah i may have an attack on the queen
side knight to b3 attacking the bishop
magnus crossing not looking to give up
his bishop yet brings the bishop back to
e7 and now we do see e3 just saying hey
yeah i want to get rid of this pawn on
d4 it is pretty annoying so we do see in
exchange bishop takes here on e3
knight two g4 attacking the bishop and
the bishop comes up here to c5 says yeah
if you want to exchange i'll exchange
off bishop so i'm not looking to trade
off my bishop for your knights here
mendes carlson decides yeah i'll just go
ahead and continue my development here
castling on the king side pawn to d4 so
just pushing trying to control the
center of the board here and then
madness crossing pushes forward with
pawn to a4
we do see the exchange here on e7 after
queen takes e7 then knight two c5 it's a
little outpost here for this knight on
c5 and then madness carlson plays a
three and after the pawn takes what i
really like about madness crossing is i
feel like most people in this position
they're just gonna take down with their
rook on a3 says yeah that that was a
great exchange i'm gonna get an active
rook here this makes a lot of sense and
i think it's a really good play but
madness carlson just looks at this and
says double pawns completely fine
you got upon a material i can get that
back at any point i'm in no rush so i'm
just going to continue with my normal
game plan of developing controlling the
center of the board and so he wants to
get his other rook active you always
want to put your rooks on semi-open
files or open files that's exactly what
madness carlson does brings his rook to
d8 attacking his pawn so he's got his
rook and his knight both eyeing down
this pawn on d4 this pawn also is the
defender of this knight on c5 so you
always want to think about what material
is defending uh specific pieces for your
material for your opponent and then how
can you attack that material so rook to
d8 doing a good job of attacking this
pawn on
d4 so recognizing that the knight comes
back to b3 says yeah i don't want this
knight hanging out here with the queen
attacking it and it also does a good job
of adding another defender on the d4
pawn
knight comes back to f6 preparing to
maneuver a little bit and attack more of
the center of the board rook to e1 so
nepo doing the same thing madness
carlson trying to get the rooks towards
the center of the board this is
controlling the semi-open e file
and then now the queen takes here on a
three so
madness carlson doing a good job of just
allowing white to make some mistakes he
does not in this position but always
looking to to give himself an
opportunity to get the upper hand
instead of just playing that rook takes
here on a3 right away now the queen
comes to e2
we see pawn h6 pawn h4 from white was
interesting to see anytime you
fianchetto with your bishop on
the king side of the board and then you
push forward with h4 it's a little
tricky because there's a lot more room
in front of your king as long as the
major pieces stay on the board
it could be difficult to hold on to
kingside safety so something to think
about but nepo also recognizes he has to
be pretty aggressive he is down two wins
and if he doesn't try something crazy if
he stays back and plays conservative it
is not going to work against madness
crosstalk so he has to take some risk
and h4 definitely lets you know that he
is looking to come to play and hopefully
it works out for him bishop 2 d7
knight 2
e5 attacking the bishop the business
comes back here to e8 madness carlson
again not looking to give up his last
bishop here queen two e3
queen to b4 attacking this rook here on
e1 there's definitely some exchanges
that could take place where the queen
could end up taking here on e1
nepo decides yeah i just don't even want
to worry about that brings his rook to
b1 semi-open file
after the knight moves there would be a
discovered attack on the queen b4
we do see an exchange here after the
knight takes e5 then the pawn takes and
then the knight to g4 attacking the
queen the queen comes back here to
e1 and then the queen takes here uh and
just absolutely better uh to go ahead
and take the queen you don't just want
to take this pawn on c4 it looks
tempting for sure but this would be a
mistake because then white could just
play pawn to f3
or yeah pawn f3 and then the knight is
going to be trapped
so now you're going to see the knight
take on e5 and then the queen take here
that'd be a very bad exchange for maddis
charleston if you say well if the threat
of here of pawn to f3
why even give your opportunity
uh why why give your opponent the
opportunity to even take here on e1 why
not just play something like queen to e2
well in this case then madness carlson
could play h5
and now if f3 then i can come back here
to h6 so that's the reason that you're
not going to see just e
queen to e2 uh because that threat does
not actually exist so after knight 2 g4
then the queen comes back to e1 man of
charleston correctly decides yeah we
need to go and exchange here not take
this pawn on c4
now the rook's gonna swing over intake
on e1 only logical move h5 here
preparing for the same thing we talked
about if the knight needs to move
because it doesn't have any other safe
squares we do see the bishop take here
on b7 rook down to a4
and says yeah okay you're up upon a
material but i'll just go ahead and
attack this pawn here on c4
we'll get it back things will be fine
nothing to see here it is all okay and
then nepo makes
probably
the biggest mistake in the tournament up
until this point he did make one in game
eight that allowed magnus carlson to go
up and winning it
but this was a huge blunder in the game
he really should have just played f3
forcing the knight to come back here
bishop comes down e4
rook takes on c4 and completely fine
both sides are equal in material white
has a pass pawn here on the a file i
think white has a better position all in
all
but he got a little greedy and after the
rook comes down to a4 attacking the pawn
he plays the move c5 didn't find another
way to defend the pawn and so instead
he decided to push forward with his pawn
to c5 because he did not see an
immediate threat on the pawn in c5 what
he didn't think about
is that his bishop could be trapped with
the move pawn c6 you can see bishop
can't take because it's defended by the
bishop
and it can't go anywhere else because
the rooks are doing a good job of
attacking it so all of a sudden magnus
carlsen has the threat rook to a7 and
the bishop is going to fall
that's not very good getting into the
end game against magnus carlsen
pawn to f3 attacking the knight sure
knight comes back h6 rook 2 e4
rook 2 a7 attacking recover 2 b4
defending but that is completely ok
because rook to b8 adding another
attacker on this bishop and it's going
to fall no way around that so pawn a
four rook takes we do see rook to b6
magnus crosston says yeah now i'm up and
it's here i'm okay with exchanging some
material so after the exchange right
here
all of a sudden madness carlson goes
into the end game and he is looking
in a very very comfortable position
right here doesn't have to worry about
this past pawn on the a file he has his
own past pawn here on the c file and he
does have an extra minor piece so things
definitely looking up for him knight two
c5
we do see knight two f5 obviously this
knight here on h6 not doing anything so
once two start to attack uh some of
these pawns here on the king side
pawn two a5 forcing the rook to come
back to b8 pawn a6 anytime you have a
past pawn nepo's only opportunity is to
push this past pawn that's what he does
here knight takes on g3 just gobbling up
some material
knight to a4 preparing at some point if
he can to come to b6 and the b6 square
is where the knight wants to go any
other square is going to be problematic
for white but this does give him an
opportunity to play knight to
b6
pawn to c5 which i think is a fantastic
move from madness cross and we just
talked about the fact that knight to
b6 is really the play to think about and
c5 gets rid of that notion right away
and says if you want to go ahead and
take that that's fine because you take
here all of a sudden magnus carlsen
plays knight to f5 he can gobble up this
material here on h4 they can start
trading down material but it's not going
to work out for
nepo if he now plays pawn to a7 then all
of a sudden rook to a8 and you can see
this knight is no longer in the equation
it doesn't it doesn't help at all it
really wants to be here on b6 where can
it really go from here and so that's why
c5
it may not look like a good move because
it's just giving up upon a material but
managed carlson is looking at it he's
seeing the threats that are possible and
he's just trying to remove them even if
it means giving up material nepal
realizes that that's not going to be a
good option for him he cannot take his
knight off of the square right now and
he plays pawn to a7 you can see the
threat here because let's say madness
carlson looks at this like a mere mortal
and says oh a7 i have to just play rook
to a8 i need to stop this threat okay
well now white has knight to b6 as we
talked about
and now there's no real way to to stop
this he's going to lose material you
either have rook taking here and then
you know the rooks is going to fall or
probably the better option which madness
carlson would play is bishop 2 c6
and after the knight takes then the
bishop takes and then magnus cross has
to worry about the pawn promoting for
the rest of the game so
after we see a7
madness carlson correctly plays rook to
d8
and now you can see that
it doesn't really uh allow for this move
knight to b6 nepo decides okay i'll go
ahead and take here on
c5 i'll take that pollen and material
but at the end of the day this is
exactly what madness carlson wanted
there's just no good option here because
after knight to seize five
then the rook to a8 and now this is game
over no way for nepo to continue his
knight is no longer involved into the
action and this is good game so nepo
resigns with the white pieces magnus
charleston goes up
three points
in this series it is not looking good
for ya nepo manas carlson only needs
three draws out of the last five games
uh he has six points to three he needs
seven and a half points total to win
madness carlson just dominate doesn't
matter white pieces black pieces the guy
does not make a mistake if you give him
just the smallest window he is going to
capitalize he's going to crush you and
he's probably going to be the world
champion yet again because that's what
madness carlson
does so exciting match you know it's
nice to see yannippo trying something
different
trying to be pretty aggressive but he
did make a huge blunder and it cost him
uh you definitely can't give up your
bishop get it trapped and expect
anything different but hopefully you
guys enjoyed
game number nine i know at the beginning
of this entire series many of you are
thinking oh man we are gonna see
just 14 draws go to a tidebreaker we
have not seen that at all three of the
last four games have all been
victory so pretty exciting stuff uh if
you're a fan of chess you're seeing the
highest level play and it's been fun but
thank you guys so much for watching the
video and i will see you guys tomorrow
for madness charleston coming back in
game number 10 with the white pieces to
see if he can get even closer to the
world championship
you